a longtime friend Charley Steiner here
on the Richer hi there good to see you
what is it like I mean you've been
you've called sports for quite some time
you don't mind me saying fifty-five Oh
what is it like watching a team win 69
of the first 100 games of anything
Charlie it really has been a remarkable
run because I don't know that anybody
expected what's happened this year
Cody Bellinger arrives out of nowhere
and now he's a second leading home run
hitter and half of his home runs have
been clutch Seeger in his second year is
a big star Turner is having a breakout
year and on April the 1st if anybody in
sports knew who Chris Taylor was right
they were a better man than we were and
he was the 26th man on the 25-man roster
and now he has shown up and has had a
sensational season the pitching has been
really solid yeah III made the
comparison last week I'm watching the
Dodgers play I guess we were in Chicago
at this team the 2017 Dodgers remind me
of the 98 Yankees and think about it for
a minute
the Yankees 114 they were probably the
best constructed baseball team that I've
seen in my career because in 98 Jeter
was just in his third year no sign that
he was going to be a hall-of-famer
Bernie Williams had a great year the
Yankees had a switch-hitting catcher
Posada mm-hmm
Dodgers have a switch-hitting catcher
Grandal very similar and how they go
about their business they had Brosius
and Tino at the corner he did the
Dodgers now have Bellinger and Turner
who's sitting about 370 at the corners
the so I was like and I it's more than
the players themselves that are similar
it's how they go about their business
they're relentless
they one through eight or 9 in the
batting order
everybody's been dangerous Taylor has
just turned into a great player the
question is is he a good player having a
great year or is
a great player at the beginning of an
amazing career well I guess and I guess
that's for future years sir come in in
the here-and-now
I mean Bellinger revelation doesn't
really do what he has done justice who
is he I mean I know he's clay
Bellinger's son and we know he hits
clutch homeruns and we know he doesn't
know who Jerry Seinfeld is I mean
outside other than that who who is
Coffelt act that he is clay Bellinger
son I think is a big deal
clay Bellinger was a utility player it
was just struggling to hang on who's in
the Yankee organization I saw him affair
about in New York when actually I was
calling the ESPN games and we spent a
lot of time with the Yankees spent a lot
of time with the Braves and a lot of
time with the Indians just because they
were an attraction and Bellinger was had
to work every step of the way to
maintain you know a three-year career
and so Cody unbeknownst to me way back
when would be in the clubhouse every
once in a while it was about 2 years old
or whatever was in fact Ehlinger last
night facing Bartolo cologne was a year
old when cologne made his major league
debut a year old one Seeger was 2 so you
see these kids evolve and you know some
of their parents and I think the fact
that clay Bellinger had to work so damn
hard just to maintain a brief
major-league career was not lost on Cody
he understands how hard it is to succeed
and we'll find out over the course of
time how to maintain Charley Steiner
here in the Rich Eisen show studio and
the fact that we've been talking about
all these physician players and how
young they are and how good they are and
we haven't even mentioned yasiel puig
name yet once shows about what we're I
guess how he has been rehabilitated is
that a good word for dry wood he's
beginning to grow up when he first
arrived June 3rd 2013
he was this brother from another planet
who was this guy
all these remarkable things then he
probably got lost in himself for a
couple of years but I think what has
happened a he's grown up B there's never
been a question about his unparalleled
athletic skills and I could say this
with a fair degree of certainty he's the
best defensive right fielder in the game
period he covers more ground than
anybody else you'll see at least a
highlight at night and the stuff that he
does his throwing arm is the best in the
game and so and he's also hitting 250
he's batting eighth in the lineup and
he's hit 18 home runs so when you look
again at the Dodgers 1 through 25 or the
starting 8 when you're eighth hitter
hitting 18 home runs you know you're on
to something pretty good and you've got
this kid Bellinger's got 28 home runs if
you prorated that over 162 games how
many home runs are think he's done 57
crazy 57 and a hundred and thirty six
RBIs and he came up 20 games into the
season well that home run your desk
started our segment did you call it was
a curveball on the outside part of the
plate he spanked it to straightaway
center field the problem was it was a
third consecutive curveball thrown by
Rogers last night and so he leaned on it
and all those are mistakes that normally
you know you can't make to a veteran
right and now you're seeing somebody of
his age do that so let me ask you this
before we take a break before we get to
Kershaw on other aspects of it first off
what does Dave Roberts done that
Mattingly could not is that a fair
question I know I had surely two
questions in one Bob what do you know I
think I think it's true in any line of
work whether it's radio television
running a fruit stand the the
temperament and mood of the clientele is
reflective of the boss Donny was of
older school he saw the game played one
way he learned at the Nev Joe Torre he
played that way up Dave is 44
Donnie's 55 or 56 I think he is better
able to relate to the younger player to
some degree and one of the things that
made Robert such a terrific player he
was cerebral he was really smart and one
of the things that Dave is able to do
watching a night in and night out at a
strategy as a strategist he's very very
good he's got a lot of parts to play
with he has a bench that he is able to
use judiciously and winning begets
winning begets winning and right now
these guys show up to work every day
thinking maybe even knowing they're
going to win that night and 69 percent
of the time they have and Dave Roberts
could steal a base right brockman I
called that one too when he can rich you
can see the whole world knows he's
stealing he can steal they 2004 I
remember doing that doing the Yankees
and there is at first base pinch running
and everybody who's going to run
Mariano knew he's going to run Posada
knew he's going to run and it was a
great throw and you knew at that given
moment the Queen Mary was beginning its
u-turn so it was a countable handoff
inside
Fenway Park when that moment happened
and a Kevin Millar had a couple other
guys before that game said to me a in
front of their dugout were just talking
and they said if we win tonight we're
going to run the table because of the
pitching match and then when that stolen
base happened I remembered back with
what Millar said and Kevin Youkilis with
the two guys mmm we win tonight we're
going to run the table yeah yeah he
stole they won and the table got run
back in 60 seconds with Charley Steiner
will talk Kershaw and then what the
Dodgers might be thinking of doing with
that 11 and a half game lead in the
trade deadline just around the corner
just like another segment with Charlie
is back in 60 seconds
[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
Charley Steiner callin tonight's Dodgers
twins game at Dodger Stadium tonight as
he did last night with Cody Bellinger's
go-ahead three-run shot in the 8th
inning for the now 69 and 31 Dodgers
joining me here for another segment here
on the Rich Eisen show how concerned are
the Dodgers about Kershaw's back best
you can tell Charlie they have to be how
can they not be last year he missed two
months he had basically a full month
then to get himself as together as he
could be for the postseason all the
while he was gone the Dodgers were like
13 games over 500 but one of the things
I learned from my days with the Yankees
and just being around baseball there are
two seasons 162 games which is an
appetizer yes and the Yankees used to
treat it as an inconvenience and then
there's a second season where you have
to win 11 games and only one team can do
that they're all fighting to win that
the final game of the World Series and
11 games is what gets you there where he
is now two days after the injury and
where he is going to be on September 1st
or October 1st I flunked biology in high
school and college all I know is if
you've got a bad back and he had a bad
back last year yeah it ain't good
so what his status is how far away he
realistically is to being back to
Kershaw who when given 3 runs of support
is a hundred and ten and eight so he is
he's a once-in-a-generation pitcher and
when you lose somebody like that how can
it not be significant how significant
that's that's why they play do you think
this changes their plans and what they
might do I have no idea I have no idea I
think the feeling was I wanted to get
another starter obviously they felt good
about Kershaw wood is having a career
year another career year yeah player for
the Dodgers Rich Hill has become a much
more reliable pitcher and
from the second month on to now so you
got three can absolutely Bank on Ryu
sometimes my ena sometimes McCarthy
sometimes but you don't have the luxury
of a sometimes outstanding performance
well your your third well because you
mentioned that they said there's a
second season we got to win 11 games and
you know more than anybody that that
second season more than any sport to the
playoffs will always find your weakness
if you've got an Achilles heel playoffs
in any sport we'll find it but not
anything quite like baseball if you've
got a right fielder who can't throw if
you've got a problem in the pen with a
lefty a little behind you if you it will
find you the baseball will find that
person so why wouldn't the Dodgers go
ahead with this once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity with all these youngsters
some of whom you're wondering are they
the real deal or not
why wouldn't they go ahead and go get
Darvish go get Verlander go get maybe
Zach Britton for the back end of that
pen and when hit the win it now button
they have to be available first in the
case of Darvish Texas is still flirting
with the notion they may be able to
parallel park themselves into a wild
card
Verlander I would assume is to some
degree available he's expensive Dodgers
don't seem to be looking in the seat
cushions for Dido Charlie you know yeah
yeah I and so their long-term strategy
or they have they have protected their
precious young talent what if they had
traded Bellinger two years ago what if
they had traded Seager a year or two ago
right um so it's not a lead-pipe cinch
necessarily I think it is fair to say
they would love to get another starter
who and for how much
I don't know so of all the teams that
you've seen come in to Shabazz ravine as
the away team or you seeing as the home
team with the Dodgers on the road who's
the best was the other team that you've
seen out there go that's a pretty damn
Washington can hit from top to bottom
whether or not their bullpen talking
about blemishes suddenly showing up
about two o'clock in the morning in the
bar go yes right you understand
it's been a while Charlie wait a while
but yes I pick up what you're putting
down yes
so okay so that's what that's what they
have to come to realize and so this is
what Washington is is to meet the teams
that we've seen we saw the Cubs when
they weren't very good but one of the
things that has struck me this year and
if you talk to Scouts around the game
the quality of play is not what it once
was
what do you mean well you've got guys
who are strikeouts don't matter so they
swing from their asses all the time and
so a strikeout is is worth the
possibility of a home run the
fundamentals of the game I think have
deteriorated this little agree with you
man in the two words that drive me
insane
more than any other this year because
it's been prevalent more than any other
than this year exit velocity yeah I
don't know what honestly I don't I don't
know you know a war what is it good for
absolutely nothing well but apparently
it's worth for some pretty song again
again I'm not just at the forefront of
exit velocity in Warren I guess I don't
know what the hell it means yeah what I
do know is if they've got one more run
than the other guy they with Terry
Collins god bless him said you know
isn't it amazing how many good players
have good numbers
hello yeah so yeah I fundamentally don't
understand that stuff uh I
we will e Keeler hit him where they
weren't it worked for him yeah so again
I'm of the age where my baseball cards
were ruined by the spokes and mush win
races but I looked at the back of the
card and I could tell you was a pretty
good player or not right so all that
stuff they may see stuff that I don't
and clearly they do but you're around
the Dodgers in all the time aren't the
Dodgers one of those teams that takes a
look at every decimal point check every
spot and everybody's positioned in a
certain way based on what the metrics
say and that's the sort of stuff that
drove Mattingly nuts apparently a
reportedly that robbed
which is actually more into than
Mattingly it's kind of Dodgers at the
forefront of this whole bat and I go
back to what Terry Collins said good
players have good number yeah and we
have a lot of good players it is it's a
very interesting lineup you've got a lot
of speed you've got a lot of power
they're not well Bellinger's now the
real home run hitter but again when when
you got a guy like play hitting 18 home
runs batting eighth well ok again I'm
not suggesting that those numbers don't
matter I fundamentally don't understand
before I let you go Charlie what was it
like having a front row seat to Vince
final season what was that like for your
VIN was we would not be talking had
there not been Vin Scully because when I
was 7 years old for summer listen to him
on the radio in New York is the voice of
the Brooklyn Dodgers I put my ear to the
speaker and I was taken that's what I
wanted to be when I grew up I wanted to
be the Dodgers announcer but then they
moved when I was 8 and that pissed me
off but I knew what I wanted to be and
so then through happenstance I became a
Dodger announcer in 2005 and became
friends with a guy that I wanted to be
when I grew up and over the course of
the years he came a very close friend a
father mentor like figure a guy that
Rick Monday and I had dinner with a
hundred times a year before every game
so we became very close and so to watch
the he was the only guy who had a going
away tour that came to him people were
to show up line outside the booth like
it was a delicatessen I'm next and he
would and so to watch all of that and
and then to spend the time that I did
with him was as cool a process as cool a
years I've ever had and were we still
talk on the phone a couple of times a
month how's he doing doing great he
loves the idea that he's retired he is
that right yeah always
when he walked out the doors kind of
like Earl Weaver closed the door
days done and he likes being home he
likes taking the car to the carwash he
likes going to Costco
he likes sitting around and reading the
paper in the morning and he is happy in
his life and I can say that without
reservation so wherever VIN is living
here in the Los Angeles area somebody
walks in trying to buy a cereal or get
the get get the shine buffed on their
car they could turn and see Vin Scully
standing right next to them in mine I
suppose if you live in the neighborhood
I'd love that Charlie you're the best
man thanks for coming in thanks for make
this a regular thing if you are so
inclined chat your odd okay Charlie I
know that I do I don't I don't do I know
you know I know that trust me I know
that and I greatly appreciate that we go
back a day yeah I don't want to say how
far back all right because you're Chuck
you're just a child
Charlie starter Colin tonight's Dodgers
kanka win their 70th freaking game
tonight to go 39 over yeah it's a number
access but you know again I go back to
what I say this is great they're doing
they're playing better than anybody they
have to win 11 in October the drama
continues Charley Steiner here on the
Rich Eisen show your phone calls when we
come back
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
video be sure to download our apps don't
have any memory on your phone let's
start to delete some of those slo-mo
videos you have and you know which ones
I'm talking about